whats up guys its prestige and where we
left off I just gets creeper now I just
picked up the goods and what I noticed
is I want to make this look not crappy I
want to make it look something uniform
so I'm going to be doing that right now
my got some iron cook let's see I'm
going to just back this up then you get
my optifine not define them my auto
switch or mod back since that thing is
quite helpful block just block that off
and I'm never going to be in here but
still I don't want it to look so
terrible every time I came in here and I
might make it into a mouse owners I'm
not really sure how to make a spider
mouth on her I know like the physics of
other mobs I'm just not sure that of a
spider in terms of climbing up stuff
that look good looks better okay I'm
gonna leave like that ok yeah whatever
is good now what to do I kind of I think
I'm going to continue my mining
escapades personally k let's go I want
that beef au throw some of this iron in
the brewery and I will chop you down
chop chop so I'm actually been up shanta
pretty surprised that I oh is that cool
that's cool I won't say pretty surprised
that I haven't seen her around but I do
hope we see him since it's been quite
elusive up to now and the MA the mod is
was I make it it's not like it's gonna
be a he's going to be everywhere like
the I know the other one working summon
him I think people summon him like a lot
and then he's like always there this one
is he's like a back of the game mechanic
it's like normal survival and then hair
brown every once in a while Cole pockets
are so nice so nice and sexy so yeah you
guys have been loving the hair brown
hair in Silicon aceite Survival Series
so I will obviously keep doing it
let's play some more not a sheep as well
can't really do much with all of them
like make a pretty something that's
pretty so I'm gonna move you once i get
like somewhere iron i'll do that
probably should fix that hole in the
back my house who bricks bricks in here
I can make I know with bricks I can make
this is the first time of every flower
pot flopped let's pick another one boom
and we're set wins it's up flowers I'll
get those red ones later I'll be quite a
gal I want the deadlines on with this
flower is the deadline
blue 20 it's nice very pretty but to
preserve move some owners and I probably
want to stack these with some coal so 16
I'll put the bat I'll put 16 you and now
I don't need don't need I don't need I
don't need Oh tell me that don't need I
want to start a farm too good I did say
I was gonna mine and last time I last
time I think I was making the staircase
since my recording of these has been
quite non unison oh oh dang happens when
you look at Heron Rosie
I've got a little bit of feeling comes
with playing this anchor safe for now
that's some cold whoa because the modest
on progress at work I didn't want to oh
did he place that the mod is still in
progress so they're going to add in and
a blood dimension which is where my hair
brynlee supposed hoang oh come on broski
broski come on no vtec and it can attack
me and Lily read up on the mod some
freaky stuff but they're adding in a
blood dimension so if you start him too
long he can teleport you that
now I should continue my mining
escapades but I feel like he's going to
pop out of me mmm the risk I must take
this makes the game significantly
creepier I would make a better staircase
without take a lot longer like I would
break the very top lock you guys
probably but you just probably don't
want to see that show I shouldn't do it
I know you guys probably want to see me
just share cason but it was for the name
of science and by that I mean I'm going
to get to bedrock and I'm going to
eventually find diamonds do that strip
Mountain craze I guess more iron that's
good and I forgot to set a timer again
I'm age it whatever i'll try and make is
115 well they are we yet part 38 so
we're kind of close I really was so a
good distance away from the bedrock this
is tedious but this is a part of I could
just go for search for cavern hopefully
I'll hit a cavern like this I'd only
have the caverns entire time that would
really shook
I'm not going to shoot mine today but I
just want to get it ready yes here's the
Emerald very nice we got some emerald
your are in extreme Hills biome so it
makes sense things gonna be night time
when I gave it to my house oh what a
fight the mobs hopefully we don't get
ambushed like my creeper like last time
out suck well we just can't we came
quite close to seen hairpin I'm not sure
where it was though I have a bet so even
if he kills me I'll be okay nice more
iron I'll pick this stuff up
and travel close to my diamond mine and
later
we got a bunch behind so that's good hey
I like to mine for diamonds around 11 so
we'll keep right there now or turn up
Twitter tops I get my sword out of this
case just in case I get ambushed I tease
my phone I'm gonna use my phone as a
timer just to see where it is i'll just
see like how close I am to my time let
me take your love again oh that's an
Enderman I don't wanna look at you I'm
just going to get it up off all up go go
go go okay sleepy time dang I can't
sleep we gotta eat I don't want him to
break down my door so kill you guys
sleep now dang I can't creep or go away
make an iron sword
Oh half of you know I have yoona s it
now dang i can't i don't know if that
angela is just off and we can't get in
my house but I really don't want to die
I think I can't we do not want to scrape
for blow up oh I'm gonna get I'm gonna
get it wait for it there we go XP yeah i
think the Endermen is pissed off dang it
and look at them though should we pissed
off I can't move what's up nope nope
crap crap off on XP dang
that could have been the monster I was
talking about dang I was like a little
like 11 fix all this crap in the morning
dang it iron what saddening oh oh oh oh
gosh that was creepy that was creepy cuz
I want to get out of my bed cousin of my
sword equipped oh yeah we found our room
that's for sure decided to show his face
all right now is I want to build so
irrelevant oh and build an arm pick
build an iron chestplate for these
mishaps of creepiness ah dang it up i'll
use my wouldn't act so I still breaks
then i'll pick me up an iron one not
pick me up just make it we found hair in
brine still not as this name he does
like making signs those signs were
creepy as heck oh if you guys didn't
catch on my case all over india ah you
don't belong here and I'm watching you
well thank you for the signs concert I
only get one but I'm going to pick up
one there were two
however slightly what is that underman
freaking out about oh I should probably
fix this for not yeah doop doop doo doo
doo I didn't even like what what time
was okay I'm so I was gonna look what
time it didn't really look there we go
that looks normal nice i'm getting bit
of lag really he went down there I'll
screw you broke it on my place
I hate the noises to make oh my gosh
it's loud like a dying radio that's what
it sounds like yea you freaky he's
freaking out hardcore don't think he's
gonna fight me art swell up that's a
good spot than the video ad so with the
render there are guys well I hope you've
enjoyed this video I'm gonna kill you
I'm gonna kill you a good son died get
back here and fight me like a man so I'm
gonna be ending the video up really
really now go away I don't like the
sound I shall be ended in a video those
trees leaves the color ugly and I hope
you've all enjoyed this and I really
have a time where i can just attend
record like an hour of it that's why
these also love intros and outros so
enjoy I'm going to see you guys next
time if you if you made it this far
through which a few people do each time
then really make sure you leave your
like since they've got this far I think
you'd enjoy you've enjoyed this enough
to leave a like so I would really
appreciate that what no I meant to put a
pin set I really appreciate like a
comments and if you subscribe there'll
be plenty more of this series as long as
you guys are still loving it and yeah
that's basically it my name is prestige
and P suckas